le dossier people donc cette semaine on
a appris ça c'est plutôt triste
évidemment si alessandra sublet qui
divorce elle divorce mais elle a dit on
reste amis voilà c'est comme ça qu'ils
l'ont fait dont elle se sépare du
producteur clément miserez voilà et ils
ont annoncé qu'ils s'étaient séparés
mais ils étaient ensemble depuis 2011 il
avait eu des enfants mais qu'aujourd'hui
voilà la rupture se ferait d'un commun
accord sans éclat on reste amis on
protège des enfants patrick bruel aussi
à l'époque avait déclaré il n'ya pas
très longtemps le 23 septembre dans sept
à huit mains que lui aussi relations
extraordinaires avec amanda sthers
s'entendent super bien bref on s'est
quand même posé la question parce que
chez les gens normaux comme nous quand
on sait par ans arrache la gueule chez
people on reste amis c'est chic ça se
fait bien tout va bien et il paraît
maintenant il ya même une tendance un
petit peu c'est la divorce party serait
divorce à l'amitié
parce qu'elle me pose ce qui se passe
guillot on a des infos là dessus aussi
aujourd'hui on divorce comme on se marie
ce à dire qu'on fait une fête chez lui
chez les stars américaines ça se fait
beaucoup les diverses parties c'est
c'est devenu un axe de communiquer de
communication parce que on peut pas dire
c'est horrible ma vie est un désastre
vous savez la vie de madame tout le
monde intéresse personne il faut faire
rêver et donc on explique on divorce que
c'est génial donc on retourne
l'événement à son avantage
et puis en même temps mais on met une
pichenette à l'otan disant regardez
comme je suis populaire donc il ya
beaucoup les médias américains mais il
faudra organiser une fête dans un jardin
où hollywood il va à las vegas il invite
tout hollywood et agents spécialisés
là-dedans rhénan et on va dire divorce
bien sûr et puis ils s'arrangent pour
communiquer en vain regardez je suis
heureux et puis surtout ça permet de
dire je suis bankable je suis ma vie
n'est pas un drame et puis d'attirer
encore des nouveaux rails pas que katie
holmes et tom cruise en ont fait une
haie la profession nous aussi on fait
une petite soirée comme ça ouais aux
séquelles c'est quand même hallucinant
alagna des chiffres aussi évidemment sur
les divorces a évidemment c'est tiger
woods 100 millions de dollars ça lui a
coûté le plus cher que les lieux c'était
tiger woods en visant la fin c'est un
des plus chers oui et madonna guy
ritchie 85 millions absolument a qui
préfèrent ils préfèrent divorcé en
s'entendant bien parce qu'il ya trop
d'intérêts en jeu et en faisant forme
kevin costner en 94 les périodes y en a
7 millions de dollars parce qu'elle
aurait considéré que quand il a commencé
sa carrière
sa femme était à l'époque secrétaire
donc elle n'a pas pu le faire c'est
clair de son côté donc du coup bah sa
carrière à lui c'est grâce à ça va me
les donner la moitié de sa fortune
kathleen wynne et surtout qu'à l'époque
kevin costner se vendait beaucoup sur sa
fidélité
donc il a beaucoup joué là-dessus
effectivement côté monsieur parfait me
suis amusé quand je veux pas faire du
mauvais esprit mais en général les stars
restent amis quand le divorce n'a pas
coûté trop cher à celui de kehl plus
riches parce que madonna qui est versée
elle 90 millions d'euros à guy ritchie
ils sont longtemps restés très fâché
très longtemps ouais franchement c'est
lié aux six est corrélé spielberg par
don harrison ford il avait relâché à
l'époque 180 millions d'euros à sa
première femme et mel gibson qui a fait
qu avait quitté sa femme avec sept
enfants il a lâché 450 millions de
dollars
bon je pense que ça refroidit un petit
peu les rapports à prendre même où il ya
comme une différence entre les gens très
connus les stars et les gens comme nous
quand on divorce et que eux savent
exactement où ils savent exactement
combien ils vont devoir verser
puisqu'ils ont fait des contrats au
moment de se marier pour savoir ce qui
allait se passer au moment du divorce
donc tous ces chiffres ils sont énormes
mais c'est jamais une surprise pour eux
ils savent exactement comme ils vont
devoir donner ça qu'on dit on pas
c'est un beau mariage aujourd'hui on
fait un beau divorce finalement
aujourd'hui aux états unis à des grandes
stars qui ont tout intérêt à 10 ans
après parce qu'en france on peut prévoir
voir peut prévoir un peu pas la
séparation de biens comme on dit mais on
peut pas prévoir comme eux exactement
centimes à 5 centimes par avance mais
aussi en a qui restent sans la manne et
ancienneté comme kardashian avec moi ton
et c'est l'arrière d'une boîte
exactement c'est si tous les ans à la
dominion et donc à l'afld il faut pas
qu'elle divorce
et puis si par exemple beyoncé djezzy si
c'est lui qui la trompe il doit 4
millions de dollars directement donc va
se déchirent le cru 2 ça c'est vrai pour
les stars qui se sont connus et qui sont
mariés quand ajouté connu mais souvent
les divorcés plus cher ils se sont
mariés quand il n'était pas connu non
ils n'ont pas fait le contrat de mariage
à la boulette pas on parle on parle
divan à hanoi à la catéchèse qui va nous
dire ah mon mari mort sur marie moreau à
laisser si vous me parlez que d'argent
où est l'amour où il
choses positives alessandra sublet et
son mari par exemple son ex mari
maintenant ils vont partir à saint barth
quand même comme chaque année pour
rester dans la tradition des fêtes de
fin d'année pour leurs enfants il ya
quand même des choses positives je vois
là un jour où l'un des deux va avoir à
quelqu'un et ça va devenir
et puis lestat en fait mais les people
maintenant il y avait des faire-part de
mariage maintenant ils ont inventé des
faire-part de séparation est par exemple
regarder jalil lespert fait couper une
seconde une robe que j'aime bien
commencer à voir avec téléspectateurs
juste pour lancer la question parce que
j'avais oublié ce que vous pouvez
répondre avec le hashtag tpm people les
divorces de stars qui se terminent tous
bien j'y crois j'y crois pas voilà dites
moi ce que vous en pensez pour savoir si
steve wallace et si je savoure pris part
pendant les choses jolies jalil lespert
pour annoncer sa séparation d'avec sonia
rolland ex miss france
il a fait un petit tweet parce que c'est
la mode merci pour ces belles années
partage et de joie de construction et
d'apprentissage ont annoncé ces deux là
comme ça donne quoi êtes assez 13-18
cette relation mais c'est joli des
choses je suis dédié à l'or qui passe
par là allez les travailleurs la fin ce
joli livre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
surtout vous avez une telle à telle peur
du mariage cette affaire soit vous avez
des infos aussi sur les sur les
séparations notamment je crois tom
cruise fait sa ba à tom cruise voix puis
sa fille il y a eu quand même un divorce
houleux avec ils ont peut-être fait une
fête de diverses mais enfin ça se passe
très mal et donc à la scientologie
l'acquis et au milieu de tout ça c'est
compliqué et brad pitt angelina on n'a
pas encore les chiffres maintenant mais
compliquées avec les six enfants les
adoptions et c'est donc c'est quand même
rare que ça se passe bien les olympiques
en général sans le bon exemple de
montrer que quand tu maintenant tu
t'entends mal et quand tu divorces mal
comme ça fait du mal ou deux vrais
progrès devaient enlever les enfants etc
d'où le fait que maintenant tout quand
ils peuvent les stars font semblant de
s'adorer même quand il divorce parce que
c'est plus l'ambiance qu'on est dans les
coeurs en aidant leurs on se soigne les
gens auraient vite et moi j'avais leur
image moi j'aimerais moi aussi surtout
ceux qui ne divorce pas mais qui devrait
divorcées ou qui vivent plus ensemble
reste effectivement nana mais voilà
parce qu'elle a déjà des contrats
aujourd'hui peut-être les békaa me
disent que celle inverse mais des
contrats aujourd'hui qu'il ferait que
perdrait beaucoup beaucoup trop d'argent
si il divorçait et qui aurait été sa
hausse y en a beaucoup des coups comme
ça non il ya les bécanes notamment c'est
mais si c'était avec des amis au début
du mois et je te jure ils ont fait des
bisous toute la soirée alors il n'y
avait pas de caméra donc ils s'étaient
c'était il y avait peut-être car you did
you say me charrière d'evilard leur
appartement de connaître et décale
non mais